da sind wir wieder am Ende einer Woche
in der die Nachrichten aus Israel
einfach nur traurig wütend und ratlos
machen meistens alles gleichzeitig reden
wir also erstmal über das
vergleichsweise leichte Thema
Innenpolitik über die Wahlen in Hessen
und Bayern die große ampeldämmerung ja
die Ampel seit Sonntag ganz offiziell
eine Koalition der Verlierer das ist ja
so alle drei wurden Böse abgewarscht mit
dem größten Verlust in Prozentpunkten
für die Grünen
F in Hessen autsch aber sie kennen ja
bestimmt die fünf Phasen der Trauer
zuerst kommt immer Verdrängung wir haben
zweimal das historisch zweitbeste
Ergebnis in unserer Geschichte das
zweitbeste landtagsallergebnis unserer
Geschichte das zweitbeste Ergebnis unser
Geschichte wir haben das zweitbeste
Ergebnis unserer bayerischen Geschichte
das zweitbeste zweitbeste zweitbeste
zweitbeste das weweitbeste Ergebnis
unser
[Applaus]
Geschichte
yeah ye mama mama ich habe in Mathe die
sechsbeste Note
wow gut harbecks Stage Diving war
eventuell von der anderen Wahl aber der
Rest eben leider nicht der Rest war von
letzten Sonntag oder oder nehmen wir mal
die SPD
8,4% in Bayern also nicht 8,4 verloren
insgesamt geholt auch weil den Sozen die
klassischen milies wegsterben
bekanntlich und das ist traurig ich find
es traurig
und die Großstädte verloren die Grünen
in Bayern die FDP wiederum fliegt in
Bayern sogar aus dem Bayerischen Landtag
raus ne oder liberaler formuliert der
Markt hat's
geregelt gut seit die FDP in der Ampel
ist versämeln sie eine Landtagswahl nach
der anderen in Hessen haben sie so
gerade die 5% geschafft was sagt man
dazu wir haben die 5% und das ist euer
Erfolg lie
so wurde wohl selten gejubelt über den
Verlust von einem Drittel der
Wählerstimmen ja das Feiern die so viel
zum Thema FDP und Leistungsprinzip ne
und natürlich sind wieder alle anderen
ampelmusen Schuld nur nicht die FDP
Lindner sagt sie könnten in dieser
Konstellation ihre Themen nicht sichtbar
genug
machen das sind die einzigen die ihre
Themen ständig sichtbar machen ja und
zwar rund um die Uhr das gibt's doch
alles
Opposition in der Regierung funktioniert
nicht wann begreifen die das endlich die
Menschen in Deutschland wollen
konstruktive Zusammenarbeit und eine
Regierung die sich Erfolge gegenseitig
gönnt ich behaupte jetzt braucht es
Ampel Aufbruchstimmung Optimismus
richtig Bock hier perfekt verkörpert vom
FDP Generalsekretär da müssen wir uns in
der Tat noch einmal zusammensetzen und
uns überlegen was wir gemeinsam als
Koalition erreichen können oder ob wir
überhaupt in der Lage sind diese Ziele
zu erreichen
ja das macht Mut muss ich sagen mein
Gott dann macht dem Elend doch ein Ende
diese Ampel bleibt nur zusammen aus
Angst vor Neuwahlen und weil man wie in
jeder normalen Ehe dem Partner noch
möglichst lange das Leben zur Hölle
machen will ne ja natürlich es ist ja so
es ist ja
so hier ich ge ih ein Beispiel neulich
erst hat das Kabinett endlich die
Kindergrundsicherung durchgewunken also
die traurige Ruine die davon noch übrig
ist zack sich die FDP Fraktion und hat
wieder einwendee ganz ehrlich wäre das
eine tvshow ich würde längst nicht mehr
gucken ihnen sind die aktuellen Reality
Shows zu seriös und nicht Assi genug
dann freuen sie sich jetzt auf diese
cpromis das herbstwinter Frühling
Sommerhaus der Ampel Big Brother Stars
Island jeder will was anderes alle haben
immer recht und dann kommt auch noch
Claudia rot nicht zu ern sobald die
kabinettstür zu ist geht das Keife
drinnen wieder
los du
kanst und Olaf Scholz macht was er am
besten kann regungslos zugucken das
herbstwinter Frühling Sommerhaus der
Ampel Big Brother Stars Island jetzt bei
phöniix dem Trash Sender Nummer
ja kann
sein ich guck der privat nur atte und
die dritten okay immerhin haben sie das
migrationspaket 2 beschlossen das
schnellere Abschiebung ermöglichen soll
heißt es wahrscheinlich weil die Ampel
Angst hat sonst selber abgeschoben zu
werden kleiner Haken auch mit den neuen
Regelungen müssen andere Länder die
Menschen natürlich immer noch
zurücknehmen aber komm es ist ein
migrationspaket zufällig beschlossen
nach dem großen AFD Wahlerfolg vom
letzten Wochenende in Hessen ist die AFD
jetzt zweitstärkste Kraft um Himmels
willen ja in
Hessen Hein Schenk weint auf seiner
Wolke meine Damen und Herren ja über 18%
in einem westdeutschen Flächenland ich
gehe ab sofort jeden Montag
demonstrieren mit wegtüder ja das ist
eine Abkürzung westdeutsche gegen die
tyüringisierung des
Abendlandes wir gehen da so spazieren
ist egal die AFD triumphiert also
neulich noch von Olaf Scholz als
schlechte Laun Partei abgetan jetzt hat
er wohl selber welche ganz im Gegensatz
zu Alis Weidel ehrlich ich wusste das
gar nicht wie witzig die Frau ist
weitere Ausgrenzung und Diskriminierung
der Alternative für Deutschland wäre
eine undemokratische
wählerverachtung AFD gegen Ausgrenzung
und
Diskriminierung von wegen es gibt keine
Rechte Comedy funktioniert doch ja ja
was macht man jetzt was macht man jetzt
meine wir können schlecht die irten
zurückholen die haben gerade andere
Sorgen und wo wir gerade bei Sorgen sind
das hier habe ich so nicht kommen sehen
es ist mir egal dass sie in Teilen als
rechtsextremistisch gilt solange Sie die
richtigen Themen anspricht 85% der
Wählerinnen und Wähler in Bayern sagen
das ist ihnen egal hätte man in
Deutschland auch nicht für möglich
gehalten aber gut einige kennen Hitler
nur noch weil der diese vielen Sendungen
bei ZDF Info
hat ganze Redaktion übrigens auch diese
hier haben über Jahre akribisch
nachgewiesen wie rechtsextrem die AFD in
Teilen ist wozu haben wir das gemacht
18% für eine rassistische völkische
interilen ganz offiziell rechtsextreme
Partei komm mal
schnell welke sagt gerade die AFD in
Teilen
rechtsextrem ja forschbar wieso
wir sind doch auch in Teilen
rechtsextrem stimmt auch wieder kannst
weiter
abwaschen
ja ich
hab ich hätte dazu mal ein paar Zahlen
im Angebot
27% der AFD Anhänger sind laut Infratest
niimap rechtsextrem weitere 25%
ausgeprägt rechts viel besser fakt ist
die AFD hat trotz Strippenzieher höcke
eine wachsende Stammklientel auch im
Westen intern sprechen sie schon vom
Wunder von Bernt ja Mister Denkmal der
Schande und das erwähne ich nur weil
sich die AFD diese Woche so klar an die
Seite Israel stellt ja Antisemitismus
gibt es bei uns in bestimmten
muslimischen milies viel zu lange
ignoriert aber nicht nur da mehrere
afdptiker wettern gern und oft gegen
sogenannte Globalisten unter rechten ein
wirklich etabliert Code für das was
oldschool Nazis das finanzjudentum
nennen hier Peter büstron AFD Listen
platz 2 für Europa fordert das dass wir
kämpfen gegen die Kriegstreiber die uns
in Kriege aufhetzen wollen gegen die
Globalisten die uns zwangsimpfen wollten
die uns enteignen wollen die uns ja im
Prinzip versklaven wollen Globalisten
aus deiner Nachbarschaft wollen dich
zwangsimpfen und versklaven ist eine
ganz normale Partei ja und Alice Weidel
hat übrigens 2017 auf Facebook den
deutschen Schuldkult beklagt aber das
ist nur am Rande juckt ja eh keinen mehr
eine AFD Gewissheit nach der anderen
zerbröselt hier Freunde keine ostpartei
und sie sind plötzlich auch erfolgreich
bei den Jungen in Bayern holt die
Alternative 16% in der alteraggruppe
unter 30 in Hessen sogar 19%. dazu
begrüße ich jetzt Christian ehing er
leitet unsere neue Jugendredaktion J
heuteh Christian warum wählen junge
Menschen die AFD ja dier weirde
Frage du bist halt raus du weißt nicht
mehr was wir von der Jen Smash und wild
finden können Sie damit bitte sofort
aufhören sehr gern aber die Antwort
liegt ja wirklich auf der Hand Social
Media die AFD hat bei Youtube mehr als
doppelt so viele Abonnenten wie alle
anderen Parteien zusammen auch bei ti
mit Abstand die meisten Follower WoW und
womit Räumen die da ab mit Emotion vor
allem mit Angst und mit Wut die liebt
der Algorithmus werden die anderen
Parteien nie begreifen mit ihren
komischen Fakten und Inhalten bei tiktok
wollen die Kids andere Sachen sowas
hier
Beatrix von Storch kommt aus dem
Aufzug ich habe es überhaupt nicht
verstanden ja weil sie alt sind ja die
AFD dominiert tiktok sie RUL wenn man
z.B letzten Montag einen ganz neuen
Account angelegt hat und dann den
Begriff Bundestag in die Suche
eingegeben hat waren acht von Zeh
angebotenen Videos pro AFD die CDU macht
gar nichts auf tiktok dabei könnte man
auch mit Friedrich Merz durchaus coole
okay als Beispiel mer s selber ne ich me
tiktok was was folgt denn daraus sollen
die anderen Parteien auch mehr Angst
machen im Internet oder oder tanzen oder
die deutsche Geschichte umschreiben wie
dieser schlimme Seitenscheitel
hier deshalb Krieg mal raus was Oma Opa
Uroma und Uropa gemacht haben wo sie
herkam was sie gekämpft und gelitten
haben überlege was es für dich bedeutet
und macht dir eins klar sie haben gelebt
und wollen jetzt egal wo Sie sind stolz
auf dich sein jetzt egal wo Sie sind
eigentlich ganz einfach würde ich sagen
nicht wenige waren damals in der SS sind
jetzt in der Hölle aber sie haben völlig
Recht bei tiktok können die anderen
Parteien einfach nicht mit stinken ja
gut ich meine man könnte ja statt doof
tiktok Videos zur Abwechslung auch mal
Politik für junge Leute machen weil die
insgesamt gekniffen sind von Klima bis
Rente ja ist aber wahnsinnig teuer
Politik für junge viel zu teuer anderer
Vorschlag wie wär es denn damit wir
geben die Jugend auf was ja so viele
sind es ja auch nicht
mein die paar Blagen ich behaupte nur
die Boomer können diese Demokratie noch
retten Schluss mit dem Geläster über
Best Ager es waren die über 60jährigen
die letzten Sonntag in Bayern Markus
höder den Arsch gerettet haben ist das
was Gutes
Ruhe jetzt mitmachen machen Sie jetzt
mit bei unserer Aktion älter werden
gegen Rechts wir müssen alle viel
schneller älter werden und das ZDF ist
dann die sperspitze der
antifaschistischen Bewegung berö wacht
nachts auf und denkt an Bares für
rares und wenn die jungen meinen sie
müssen jetzt plötzlich AFD wählen dann
sagen wir runter mit der Geburtenrate
jede verhinderte Befruchtung ist eine
potenzielle AFD Stimme weniger deshalb
Kondome für
alle durchgedreht schade Christian ehing
meine Damen und
Herren tja eins nehme ich mir mit so
spannende Frage meine Damen und Herren
woher kommt der Rechtsruck in
Deutschland wo kommt er her Union und
Ampel haben offensichtlich zu viel Zeit
damit verpläert sich gegenseitig die
Schuld am Erfolg der AFD zu geben statt
einfach nur Probleme zu lösen gut das
ändert sich natürlich heute abend heute
Abend trifft sich im Kanzleramt eine
große Runde aus Opposition und Regierung
um endlich den deutschlandpakt zu
schmieden geh davon aus die gucken uns
alle zusammen
hallo so und welche Rolle haben
überhaupt wir Medien gespielt in den
letzten Wochen keine gute meint
irgendwer mit
Medien irgendwer mit Medien mit
Friedrich
Küppersbusch mal ehrlich Leute wie haben
wir Medien und Jungs das mal wieder
gemacht paar Wochen vor den Wahlen noch
boah nichts öder als Söder und hier rein
da raus langweilig landtagswalium keine
Klicks keine Quote da mussten wir uns in
den Redaktion doch was einfallen lassen
eine schlimme krank vielleicht
brückchenpest oder noch ansteckender
herr Doktor ich habe schlimm AFD ja und
was hilft dagegen Tabletten Zäpfchen in
Einlauf ne wird ja alles braun das
wollen wir ja gerade nicht während viele
Medien sich aufregen wie eine
durchgeknallte nenny beim Wähler
erziehen fanden sie so zu ihrem Thema
Durchfall ist ja auch nur ein anderes
Wort für Kontrollverlust unser
stillgelegter bundespastor hatte das
kracherthema für den Wahlkampf gefunden
na klar Kontrollverlust migration
Migration ist mir zu klein an der Stelle
8% und große Fresse typisch Sozi aber
gut dann sagen wir gleich
Masseneinwanderung das macht richtig
Angst alle machen mit und alte
journalistenreel ich lass mir doch eine
geile Geschichte nicht durch Recherche
versauen un sie Beispiel die
Asylbewerber sollen ja kein Bargeld mehr
bekommen weil sie das immer gleich nach
Afrika schicken jetzt nur einen
googlehupf entfernt Fakten Migranten
schicken aus Deutschland über 70% der
Kohle nach Europa Türkei Polen Italien
so lehütenländer halt vor dem ersten
afrikanischen Staat auf der Liste kommt
noch Disney World und natürlich das
Auenland noch so ein Beispiel viele
Städte und Gemeinden können ja die
flüchtlingsunterbringung nicht mehr
bezahlen dabei hatte der Bund doch 2,75
Milliarden Euro versprochen also wo ist
das Problem kollege kommt gleich sind
diese 2,75 Milliarden inzwischen an
Länder und Kommunen überwiesen worden
das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen aber in
der Reg ist so dass es da eine eine
nachträgliche Abrechnung gibt woher soll
der Regierungssprecher auch wissen was
die Regierung tut nachreckig hat er
gesagt also die Ampel macht bei den
Ländern ein Deckel wenn man solche
Fakten einfach mal weglässt schlampig
bis überhaupt nicht recherchiert und den
lieben Gott einen Wirtschaftsflüchtling
aus dem Nahen Osten sein lässt ja dann
läuft es das drängendste Thema der
Hessen aber bei dieser Wahl die
Migration irgendwann ist Obergrenze
erreicht und wir sind drüber passt und
so topmtiviert geht es mit guter
Wahlbeteiligung an die Urne kann das
Land die vielen Flüchtlinge verkraften
da sagen in Bayern
59% nein in Hessen sind es
53%. und Graf Zahl vom schurkensender
nebenan hat dann noch ein interessantes
Detail am Start mehr als die Hälfte der
Wählerinnen und Wähler der Partei sagt
ich habe wegen der Zuwanderungspolitik
die AFD gewählt ja und damit ist unsere
Forschungsfrage ja wohl klar beantwortet
was hilft gegen die AFD wir Journalisten
bestimmt nicht und damit rüber zum
Erntedankfest welches Problem in
Deutschland muss am dringlichsten gelöst
werden das ist das Migrationsproblem
Migration ist ohne Zweifel eins der
drängendsten Themen dieses Thema
Migration Thema Migration die
Migrationspolitik Migration ist mir zu
klein irre irreguläre Migration Kevin
könert sie haben es gemerkt zweimal
dabei bitte nicht
wiederwähen sagt man das bei der SPD so
was nehmen wir heute mit es war ein
spannenderer Wahlkampf ein viel
bescheuerter Ergebnis und wenn sie mal
ein Problem haben wennen sich auch
vertrauensvoll an uns haben sie bald
zwei irgendwer mit Medien mit friedich
Küppersbusch friedich
Küppersbusch
ja im Moment ist es ja so die
Nachrichten sind so deprimierend man
möchte beim Fernsehen statt erdnusflips
nur noch antidepressiver knabbern
Ukraine und jetzt auch noch der Hamas
Terror in Israel wenn die Menschheit so
weitermacht muss man den Planeten
wahrscheinlich sehr bald bei ebay
reinstellen ja ich habe es neulich
tatsächlich mal versucht blauer Planet
leichte Gebrauchsspuren Polkappen
müssten erneuert werden ideal für
Bastler nur Selbstabholer und ja zur Not
stellen wir ihn halt inner zu
verschenkenkiste an die Milchstraße ne
will eh keiner haben mein Tipp Olaf
Scholz hat gestern immerhin ein
Betätigungsverbot für die Hamas in deuts
verkündet sehr gut kurze Nachfrage warum
durfte sich eine Terrororganisation bis
jetzt bei uns
betätigen und war es wirklich gut am
selben Tag den Emir von Qatar also einen
mutmaßlichen Hammers Großsponsor zu
empfangen ja ging nicht anders ja es
ging nicht anders die sind jetzt einer
unserer wichtigsten Energiepartner hier
schreibt der EM mir gerade dem bundesuhu
ins Freundschaftsbuch in allen vier
Ecken soll LNG Gas drin stecken
ah komm komm hauptsache nicht mehr beim
Putin kaufen das machen wir doch nicht
oder was aber nicht bedeutet dass kein
russisches Gas mehr nach Europa und
somit auch nach Deutschland kommt die
Europäische Union importiert sogar
deutlich größere Mengen russischen Gases
als vor dem Angriff auf die Ukraine
allerdings als verflüssigtes LNG Gas
was ich wollte es auch nicht glauben ja
es gibt überhaupt keine gassanktion gibt
keine mindestens 4% des deutschen
gasimports kommen immer noch aus
Russland plus eine nicht genau zu
bestimmende Menge die uns über Belgien
erreicht da laufen sogenannte take or
pay Verträge das heißt wenn man das Zeug
nicht mehr nimmt muss man trotzdem
zahlen meine klar das das kennen wir vom
Handyvertrag ne man kommt nicht wieder
raus und Scholz hat's ja
versucht wenn Sie weniger Flüssiggas
bestellen wollen drücken Sie die 376
2975 Raute wenn Sie einen unkündbaren
Altvertrag haben hören Sie nun das
Lachen von Präsident
[Gelächter]
Putin ach ja der Olaf einfach nicht
seine Woche würde ich sagen insgesamt
über das was gerade alles auf der Welt
los ist freuen sich wirklich nur noch
die Feinde der regelbasierten
Weltordnung die Feinde von Terran bis
Moskau ja vor allem der Wladimir hier
hat auffallen gute Laune und das ist
kein Wunder die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine in der EU bröckelt jetzt wird
auch noch die Slowakei von Russland
Freunden regiert der Ölpreis steigt und
steigt und eigentlicher Schocker in den
USA ist das Unvorstellbare plötzlich
wieder vorstellbar oh ja genau eine
zweite Amtszeit von Donald Trump ja eine
zweite Amtszeit für den Putin Buddy der
am 6 Januar 21 wir erinnern uns um
einhar die Demokratie versenkt hätte und
und heute die hisbolla Zitat sehr schlau
nennt seine persönliche Freak Sekte die
Republikaner schaffen es gerade nicht
ein neuen Speaker zu wählen und im
usreäsentantenhaus herrschen nur noch
Chaos und wie man hier sieht mühsam
unterdrückte
Wut was kann denn der Hammer dafür
wirklich den zahlst du ja ja Trump hat
leider kein Witz wirklich Chancen
wiedergewählt zu werden dabei steht der
Mann wegen unzähliger Verfahren vor
Gericht und gibt neuerdings auch noch
damit
an Loser
nach amerikanischem Recht könnte Trump
selbst als verurteilter Straftäter die
USA regieren es ist so ja ich weiß es
klingt absurd aber es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen schon Mitte November
droht der sogenannte government shutdown
inklusive Ende der amerikanischen Ukrain
Hilfen das Vertrauen ins demokratische
System soll weiter erschüttert werden es
ist alles aus dem Handbuch des kleinen
möchte gern Autokraten und im Duell mit
Joe Biden Trump sich ohehin deutlich vor
und zwar in allen Kategorien sogar am
Strand genau Trump hat ein super Beach
body wie
hüpfbur außerdem haben wir wohl ganz
andere Probleme W wenn der wirklich
zurückkommt in etwas mehr als einem Jahr
müssten wir Deutschen uns selber um
unsere Sicherheit kümmern das können wir
überhaupt nicht dann gibt's auch wieder
Strafzölle auf deutsche Autos hör auf es
ist ein Albtraum in den Umfragen führt
Trump mit gigantischem Abstand vor
seinen republikanischen Mitbewerbern
wirklich alles läuft schon wieder zu auf
Trump Verss Biden und wir schalten mal
live nach Washington zu Dennis
knorsaller Dennis bei ihnen wird sogar
schon das Studio für die Duelle nächstes
Jahr gebaut ja es ist wohl nicht zu
ändern denn in den USA leben ja nur
336 Millionen Menschen wie will man da
einen finden außer Trump und beiden und
die fangen jetzt schon mal an das Studio
hier seniorengerecht und barrierefrei zu
machen es gibt z.B überall
Leuchtstreifen damit die beiden ihre
Pulte auch finden toll aber sag mal wird
das denn ernsthaft ein spannendes Duell
ja man mag es kaum glauben beiden
kurbelt die Wirtschaft wieder an mit
gigantischen Investitionen Trump hat zum
Sturm aufs Kapitol aufgerufen also ein
Putsch trotzdem Kopf an Kopf Rennen in
den Umfragen
Amerikaner gut am Ende entscheidet
wahrscheinlich sowieso die Biologie also
wer schafft's überhaupt noch bis zur
Wahl wer mummifiziert schneller ich
fürchte beiden wenn man alleine sieht
wie lange der braucht um seine
Strickjacke anzuziehen dann muss Mutti
helfen falscher Arm Joe warte mal mein
Gott
und wenn er es dann endlich geschafft
hat na ja
und natürlich macht Trump sich jetzt in
einer Tour über beiden lustig weil er
ist ja erst süße
[Applaus]
77 ja dann spring doch würden wir
alle eh morgen beim Iron Man mitmachen
aber wenn man dann sieht wie er selber
eine ganz normale Rampe runterwatschelt
ist das ja auch schon Pflege Stufe
3 Don hat in seinem golfrort Mar alago
neulich einem australischen Milliardär
geheime Details über atomu-boote
verraten kein Witz was alte Leute halt
so labern beim Streuselkuchen und beiden
[Musik]
wiederum
also ja gut
also sicher sicher aber beiden will
wenigstens nicht die Demokratie
abschaffen ein ziemliches plus würde ich
mal sagen gutes Argument Demokratie
worauf allerdings viele Amis Antworten
boring Politik ist Entertainment welke
deswegen wird es hier im nächsten Jahr
nach dem üblichen Geblubber auch erst
richtig spannend die bauen hier einen
Parcours mit knallharten challenges für
Senioren heute wird mit dem 84-Jährigen
lichtdubel geprobt Herausforderung 1 der
ultimative Opa Endgegner die Treppe des
Todes ah er bricht ab na ja dann das
Marmeladenglas ohne fremde Hilfe
aufmachen schafft er nicht na ja schade
und Nummer 3 super TFF beim Staatsbesuch
Olaf Scholz erkennt
nee das der häing der
apatchen ach ich glaube das können wir
gelten lassen das glaube ich aber auch
Dennis kN vielen
Dank nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den Kanal abonniert und
ein Like da lasst
ich habe die Schnauze
voll ja los lasass ein Abo
da